Let's go next to our color from the four one
zero area code.
Who's calling today from four one zero.
Hi, David.
I believe that's me.
Yes it is.
Okay.
This is Andrew.
Can you hear me?
I can.
What kind of device do you have?
Assan cause it sounds weird, Andrew.
I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
How about now?
It's much better.
Yes.
Okay, perfect.
I had a question that now that the Q three
finance, uh, information about several campaigns
has come out.
I was, uh, wondering if your analysis or predictions
have changed at all about the yang campaign.
I'm kind of undecided, but the exponential
growth, uh, was kind of shocking to me.
I didn't expect him to reach double digits,
so I was wondering if you had any on that
you're D reached double digits in what?
Uh, in terms of the millions, he just announced
that he, they raised 10 million for Q three.
Got it.
[inaudible] you're talking about double digit
polling?
Yeah, I mean, listen, you know, he's running
a good campaign and he's running a good campaign.
I don't until there's that one Emerson poll
that says yang has 8% no other poll says that
if we start seeing more polls that say that,
then I will start to believe it.
Like I don't have any particular insight into
this is what we're seeing in terms of fundraising.
This is what we're seeing in terms of polling.
This is what we're seeing in terms of debate
performance and we're all kind of in it together
trying to figure it out.
But he's certainly running a solid campaign.
Right.
Definitely.
I'm curious to see how these increase numbers,
if it changes the Polian at all.
Cause I know he's yet to really break above
3% nationally on average.
Yeah.
So we'll see how it goes, but thank you.
I appreciate your insight.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
I appreciate it.